si on veut accroître l'autonomie
alimentaire et produire des fruits et
légumes sous des latitudes nordiques
comme ici on n'a pas le choix il faut
cultivés en serre voilà pourquoi le
gouvernement du québec veut doubler la
superficie des serres de la province
tour d'horizon d'une industrie en pleine
expansion
[Musique]
oui
voici le plus récent complexe serricole
au québec certes on devra installer au
lac saint jean depuis 2016 un projet de
plus de 100 millions de dollars
17 hectares de serres bientôt 28 dès le
départ sert toundra a vu grand et plein
de légumes qui sont importés d'autres
régions que ça vienne de l'ontario que
ça vienne encore d'autres pays on a la
capacité de faire cesser au québec dans
deux fois qu'on le fait pour
c'est retournera est vite devenu un
géant du concombre de serre l'entreprise
en produits 100 millions par an anglais
nordiques et nuit livré dans les
supermarchés partout au québec dans les
72 heures suivant la récolte en quelques
années à peine certes ou draps s'est
accaparé 85% du marché québécois
puisqu'on est également de déplacer la
production qui naît de l'espagne la
production venaient du mexique
les propriétaires ont des atouts majeurs
ils ont bénéficié de garanties de prêt
de plusieurs dizaines de millions de
dollars
et ils ont misé sur la technologie de
pointe on avec un projet vraiment de
conception européenne avec des rames au
mètre carré qui n'a jamais été atteint
au québec
ils ont aussi obtenu un terrain de la
compagnie voisine produits forestiers
résolu c'est retournera couvre une bonne
partie de ses besoins en chauffage en
récupérant l'énergie produite en lead
sur bin de résolu et envoie l'eau chaude
ici on utilise l'eau chaude pour
chauffer les serres froides îlot à
chauffer les salles puis on retourne
locher résolu donc c'est gagnant gagnant
enfin l'entreprise pourra bientôt capter
le carbone générées par résolu le traité
puis l'injecter dans le complexe de
serre pour favoriser la photosynthèse et
la croissance des plants
maintenant qu'elle domine le marché
québécois du concombre toundra veut
diversifier sa production elles misent
notamment sur une culture absente des
tablettes les haricots gens ce succès
c'est beaucoup d'énergie se déteste on a
commencé à envoyer un petit peu dans les
choux mais cessez de longue haleine et
il faut juste être sûr que si on va sur
une grande échelle évidemment on va
donner un produit de qualité
des produits de serre d'ici québec
souhaite en voir plus sur les tablettes
des épiceries
la crise de l'aco vide a fait craindre
une pénurie de denrées le gouvernement
veut faire passer la superficie de
production de 120 à 240 hectares pour y
arriver il propose un club ambitieux
91 millions de dollars serviront à
moderniser et agrandir les serres
petites et grandes et à rembourser 40 %
de la facture d'électricité pour les
projets d'investissement de 3 millions
et plus grâce à un financement de 21
millions le réseau électrique triphasé
d'hydro-québec plus puissant sera
accessible à de nouveaux producteurs on
prévoit construire environ 200 km de
lignes électriques
et tous les séries cultes heures auront
désormais accès à un rabais substantiel
des tarifs d'électricité pour
l'éclairage et le chauffage
c'est exactement ce que l'un très
recherchés
andré gosselin a vu naître les premiers
grand complexe serricole au québec dans
les années 80 il a cofondé les serres du
saint laurent à l'origine du succès
commercial des tomates savoura
aujourd'hui ils cultivent des petits
fruits en serre et sous grand tunnel à
l'île d'orléans il croit que l'aide du
gouvernement profitera autant aux
grandes ou petites entreprises comme la
sienne que des programmes qui
s'adressent aux plus petites entreprises
avec des investissements qui peuvent
être 5000 $ par exemple alors ça peut
aider une entreprise a démarré ou à
construire une ou deux serres au grain
grand tunnel démarrer une nouvelle
production selon lui les rabais de
tarifs offerts pendant 8 ans sont
particulièrement importants l'éclairage
artificiel utilisé dans lé complexe
serricole permet au québec de produire
12 mois par année est de concurrencer
les producteurs plus au sud mais c'est
très coûteux d'ailleurs dans le passé
des producteurs ont connu des
difficultés financières et déclarer
faillite parce que les tarifs
préférentiels d'électricité offert par
le gouvernement de l'époque n'ont pas
duré assez longtemps
actuellement on a des surplus
d'électricité
pensent que l'utiliser chez nous pour
produire nos aliments créer des emplois
créer de la richesse tu sais pas c'est
pas un gaspillage pense que c'est une
une politique qui est intelligent
sylvette héros a connu les hauts et les
bas de l'industrie serricole québécoise
depuis 30 ans il est à la tête diderot
serre les laitues bostons hydroponique
ont fait la renommée de l'entreprise au
canada et sur la côte est américaine
hydro serre est en pleine expansion et
va profiter du programme dead
à l'été 2000 20 sylvain perreault a fait
l'acquisition des anciennes serres de
tomates savoura à port neuf on parle de
trois hectares et demi qu'on est en
train d'aménager un système de culture
en eau profonde pour la les reçus
quelques mois plus tôt il a pris les
rênes dessert le fort en montérégie un
producteur de poivrons et de concombres
bio qui croulait sous les dettes quels
secteurs traditionnels de serre
devraient être construits sur le site
hydro sert espère ajouter la tomate à sa
gamme de produits biologiques produire
des fines herbes et même développer de
nouvelles variétés de laitue on verra ça
va nous amener la laitue romaine est
sûrement un au nos produits qu'on
travaille très fort actuellement
l'innovation c'est le mot clé les
producteurs québécois occupe seulement
30% du marché des produits de serre
consommés au québec selon la pdg de
l'association québécoise de la
distribution de fruits et légumes
l'appétit des consommateurs et grands la
fraise la framboise
il ya un engouement extraordinaire pour
les québécois qui sont même parfois
prêts à payer un peu plus puis on a
beaucoup de communautés ethniques ou six
au québec en fait que toutes les légumes
asiatiques aussi connaissent beaucoup de
succès pour sophie perrot le vent
d'optimisme qui souffle sur l'industrie
serricole québécoise va profiter aux
gros mais aussi aux plus petits
producteurs je pense que l'on il ya de
la place aussi pour es un petit cheval
qui souvent justement sont plus
flexibles plus agile peuvent peut-être
faire plus de tests et essayer plus de
choses
elle croit d'ailleurs que le québec
pourrait faire sa marque en développant
davantage le créneau biologique surtout
que nos compétiteurs ontariens et les
autres sont peu présents dans ce marché
de niche là et la catégorie du bio est
en augmentation de 19% ce moment dans
les commerces de détail pour le fruit et
légumes
charles verdi est bien conscient de tout
ce potentiel on offre depuis trois ans
la gamme biologique on est
particulièrement fier de cette gamme de
produits là parce qu'au départ quand on
s'est lancé dans le biologique qui
existe est pratiquement rien donc les
engrais n'était pas disponible il
fallait être créatif l'ingénieur a
quitté sa profession il y a quelques
années et fait l'acquisition de serres
de tomates et de fines herbes à
saint-norbert dans lanaudière
aujourd'hui les herbes gourmande
produite uniquement des fines herbes en
pot charles verdi se prépare à investir
10 millions de dollars dans ses
installations
dans mon corps on y les plus petits des
plus grands si on peut dire on a
l'intention de doubler notre superficie
d'un auxerre cette année avec un seul
hectare de serre il produit actuellement
une trentaine de variétés de fines
herbes et de l'est dessus et dessert les
trois grandes bannières présente au
québec
selon lui il y a encore de la place dans
le marché des herbes fraîches en pot ses
soeurs font valoir dans un premier temps
de servir à 100% le marché québécois en
fines herbes et en zambie biologique
mais si les surcoûts de production
on n'est pas fermés non plus aller à les
exporter dans deux provinces
[Musique]
charles verdi a déjà investi dans des
installations électriques plus robuste
en prévision de l'agrandissement
l'ingénieur serriculteurs envisage aussi
de tomates is et une partie de ses
opérations
il voit l'avenir avec optimisme
il n'est pas seul les annonces
d'investissements se multiplient
acquisition modernisation agrandissement
la liste des projets s'allonge à coups
de millions voire de dizaines de
millions de dollars
[Musique]
andré gosselin croit que l'industrie a
tiré des leçons des erreurs du passé
quel est maintenant prête à passer en
deuxième vitesse et qu'on pourrait même
voir de nouveaux joueurs s'installer au
québec
c'est certain que plusieurs entreprises
agricoles ou horticole qui était pas
nécessairement talent d'un dessert qui
aujourd'hui s'intéresse à l'acériculture
ça fait pas de réponse est que de plus
en plus de ces entreprises le québécois
ou des partenariats au québec avec
d'autres entreprises étrangères vont
être puis s'installer au québec
[Musique]